this is the U.S forest Service fire lab
where scientists research the elements
that make up forest fires the Flames the
trees the soil the smoke and the
wildlife
welcome to wired field trip
[Music]
this is research Forester Mark Finney he
studies fire Behavior
we're here in the Hall of the of the
fire lab experimental wing and right
behind me are the double doors which
take us into the burn chamber these
scientists engineer instruments where
they can recreate conditions of
wildfires
apparatus here we call Big Sandy it's
designed specifically to look at the
effects of slope on the flame
characteristics and on the spread of the
fires and you can already see a change
in the flame structure from when it was
horizontal right these Flames are
deflected almost level with the platform
you're going in and then they curve up
the reason fires are spreading faster
uphill than downhill is because of the
fire itself the hot flames are rising
and in order for them to rise their
drawing air in from the sides as we
increase the angle we're going to see
the Flames permanently attached to the
surface and they will not rise up off
the ground it illustrates One important
principle of Wildland fires that you
don't want to be uphill of a spreading
fire because it can spread very very
rapidly and be very dangerous
here is a demonstration of a surface
fire through cardboard that's
Burns only what's known as Forest litter
this fire is not burning the ground
fuels themselves like the litter or
organic material in the soil but just on
the surface it's the movement of a fluid
in this case flame is a fluid past an
object that either Heats or cools it by
that contact we burn many different
configurations of driven conditions to
try to isolate the individual processes
and study them separately one behavior
that marks team studies is what's known
as a fire whirl so this is a fireworld
generator fire worlds are an important
phenomenon that occur in y lands and
they occur naturally and they occur very
very frequently fire whirls are one of
the most dangerous elements of a
wildfire for firefighters they have an
erratic spread rate and a rapid increase
in fire intensity they create very very
strong surface winds that are much
different than the ambient conditions
around a fire whirl in 1923 in Tokyo was
estimated to kill 38 000 people in less
than 15 minutes the fire lab studies how
they form and spread fires need the
oxygen from wind to spread Mark's team
studies that too just like we study
slope independently of other factors
here we need to study the effect of wind
on fire spray this is called the
carousel burner because it's a burner
but it rotates and we're able to rotate
the flame Zone relative to the wind
direction Mark's team converted a grain
bin in order to study bigger fires
behold the grain bin
this is our newest experimental facility
and the purpose of this facility is to
understand pretty much how large Woody
fuels and deep Duff layers deep organic
layers burn they usually burn in one of
three ways they either don't burn or
they burn as flaming or they burn a
smoldering and the fact is we have no
idea what conditions determine which one
of those ways that they burn these
experiments translate to predicting how
fire will behave in a wildfire scenario
right now the current model does not
account for different fuel types and
other variables but Mark's team is
changing that one thing that the early
researchers here didn't understand was
convection it's very difficult to make
measurements of convection in a
spreading fire so that's our main
mission here is to understand how the
processes of combustion heat transfer
and ignition all produce a spreading
fire someday the research that we're
doing here will be mature enough to be
transferred into a model form but it has
to address a lot of the other behaviors
next we're going to talk to ecologist
Sharon Hood her team studies Forest
restoration
by knowing how trees grow and how fires
can scar these trees we can see how they
survive and are resilient to fire while
the Forest Service previously thought
that we needed to put out all fires
there is scientific evidence America's
forests are fire dependent ecosystems
the trees survived many fires before
colonialism this sample from a ponderosa
pine where each of these years
represents a fire so
1675 is the first fire this tree
survived it killed a little bit of the
cambium and then it the tree survived
and kept growing and it starts to curl
around that scar if we do this with
dozens and dozens of samples over a
whole area we can stack those years up
in compare and see how spotty a fire was
if it was patchy just in a really small
area or over a large area and how many
of the trees survived we have probably
thousands of tree cores Sharon's team
drops into a forest after fires and
samples them she's going to demonstrate
what coring a tree looks like I'm trying
to hit the very center of the tree all
branches point to the center of the tree
so that's a good clue
[Music]
each light and dark band together forms
one year's worth of growth and so these
rings are really wide and evenly spaced
so that means it's growing the same
amount every year let's follow Sharon
back into the lab where they prepare
samples to study the trees all the way
down to the cell structure so this is
one of the fuels ovens where we can dry
samples this is a core microtome rotary
microtome this allows us to make
microscope slides to be able to look at
the cellular level what's going on in
the tree and this is just the tip of the
iceberg there are so many different
kinds of samples in this fire research
facility let's take a look at the soils
lab
welcome to the soils lab I'd like to
show you our soils that we experiment
with over the years I've worked here
we've collected soil samples large cores
12 inches in diameter six to eight
inches deep everywhere from Alaska to
Florida this is a demo of Slash pile
burning that was part of an experiment
that we did to look at factors
influencing heat transfer into soil
we're collecting temperature data below
the soil surface my temperatures oh 200
300 degrees right now and they're going
up very quickly
so what you have is a large amount of
heat being generated but it's all going
up we estimate only at between five and
ten percent actually goes down into the
soil but long after the Flames are gone
that's when the soils are actually being
affected as you can see from the the
data acquisition system it's still
heating up you still have unburned fuel
that's smoldering that's glowing
combustion and if the wind picks up it's
going to take that campfire and blow it
into the the trees next to your campsite
or or something burnable put your
campfires out for science so now we've
looked underneath the forest the actual
trees what about all of that smoke the
Missoula fire lab studies that too
do I like this one will kill first yeah
yeah generally like
the Smoky smell that's how I make my
living is smoke so I
can't really complain right now we're
going to demonstrate one of the methods
we used to collect smoke samples which
we then bring back to the lab for
chemical analysis this is the sampling
system we use for ground-based emissions
for low intensity fires where we can
walk directly up to the fire and take
the samples so we open the canister the
canister is evacuated and then it starts
filling with the emission sample we try
to position this the sample probe
obviously where the emissions are coming
off the fire
the scientists then take these Wildfire
emission samples to their gas
chromatography lab
profiles all the different gases
different hydrocarbons in the sample as
well as Co and CO2 over 99 percent of
the carbon emitted will be as CO2 and
that goes down as you get a much less
efficient fire when you have a lot of
smoldering that's the kind of situation
that causes a lot more pollution and air
quality issues most typical forest fires
are kind of a mix of the two the results
of our studies we basically come up with
what we call emission factors and those
are numbers that can be used by air
quality agencies to estimate pollution
as wildfires grow in intensity and
frequency the effects of smoke are being
felt by more people air quality is a
hazard but what science teaches us is
that fire can actually be good for the
ecosystem in most of North America
we have what we call fire dependent
ecosystems the vegetation nation and
Wildlife and pretty much all of the
ecosystem components depend to in
different ways on different kinds of
fire and so there has been some research
especially in the Pacific Northwest
working with some of the tribal
communities that the smoke cools the air
down and it creates a little bit more of
that shading for the streams and the
small rivers that's a benefit for
species like salmon so every component
of fire from you know the actual
activate you know going through and
burning woody debris to then the smoke
that it creates and then the benefits
after that fire are just so numerous
ironically many of these scientific
conclusions are actually catching up to
ancient practices we cannot talk about
wildfires in America without talking
about Native American Cultural burning
this is biologist Sarah Hoagland she's a
tribal liaison officer for the Missoula
fire lab her research focuses on a
threatened species of owls
in 1910 around Western Montana we had
what was known as the big burn after
that the forest service and the agency
decided to go towards more fire
suppression portraying fire as sort of
an enemy and that we need to just
get rid of it and extinguish it the
forest service enacted what's known as
the 10 a.m rule every fire should be
suppressed by 10 a.m following its
report our fire suppression policies
that we've enacted over the last hundred
years it's created extremely dense
forests we now are experiencing more
severe more frequent higher intensity
fires in our forest because those fuels
have built up for so long a combo of
these fire suppression tactics and
drought conditions due to climate change
are part of the reason why wildfires are
getting worse on top of forest service
policies their PR campaign around fire
suppression focused on how fires were
threatening adorable creatures there are
so many cartoons that show fire as an
enemy
if you were to change the you know PSA
only you can prevent forest fires how
would you change it oh man
we need fire many species actually
depend on fire enter the Mexican spotted
owl Sarah's been following this adorable
creature for many years I study the
Mexican spotted owl in South Central New
Mexico with the Mescalero Apache tribe
it's threatened because of high severity
stand replacing fire that impacts its
habitat the tribe that I get to work
with they are very active with their
Forest management and so they do a lot
of thinning and prescribed Burns around
their owl sites and so some of the
things that we've found with our
research is that moderate level of
thinning has reduced the risk of fire
but also maintain the habitat for the
species and so the tribe has really been
able to figure out that balance for
their Forest we know wildfires are
getting worse but the good news is that
we know why and we know how to fix it
you know if you look at this and the
other research we're conducting here I'm
very optimistic I don't think all of our
problems are going to go away but I
think science is going to provide us at
least some good directions to go
scientific knowledge and practical
knowledge is already well developed that
would allow us to vastly improve our
ability to manage fire the challenges of
course in the way our culture utilizes
that or doesn't utilize that information
that I have less confidence in but
certainly I know very well that our
science and our and our our knowledge is
sufficient to do a better job should we
should we as a society decide to do that
taking something like fire out of the
forest is like taking water out of the
forest it's something that the forest
needs and it relies upon there are so
many other experiments going on at the
Missoula fire lab that we don't have
time for this team studies lidar mapping
to see how forest fires travel this team
conducts experiments on how rifle
bullets ignite fire in the future
scientists hope to predict where
wildfires spread and how and save our
forests along the way
wow I don't know if I've hugged the tree
in a while but for now we will leave the
scientists behind to play with fire and
that's our wired field trip see you next
time